[Music]
will you believe that the mosquito is
responsible for more human deaths than
any other living creature when it sucks
your blood it can transmit diseases like
malaria yellow fever encephalitis and
West Nile virus of course a mosquito
takes quite a journey before it's
prepared to make a plasma withdrawal the
four stages of its life cycle are egg
the female lays her eggs in water she
often lays over 200 eggs at a time and
the eggs can survive five years before
hatching larvae the larva feeds on
microorganisms in the water which is why
places with plenty of stagnant water
like the Everglades or last summer's
abandoned wading pool in the backyard
are good breeding grounds then there's
pupae which is just a quick non feeding
transitional phase and finally adult
ready to join the billions of airborne
blood suckers a female may live about a
hundred days by the way only females
insert their blood siphon into your skin
and drink your life essence they need a
blood meal in order to produce eggs
males are satisfied with nectar from
flowers now to be fair there are 3,000
mosquito species around the world many
don't bite humans preferring other
species and finally you're more likely
to get bitten if you have smelly feet
mosquitoes like women who are ovulating
and blondes more than brunettes and
biting activity increases 500 times
during a full moon which does not help
their reputation as creepy creatures